many people this Thanksgiving will be
making the ethical choice of eating
tofurkey but those who truly have a
conscience will make sure their topher
keys come from organic free-range
Tofurky farms like this one
McClellan farms
so Ronald what is the McClellan
difference well we don't look at these
things as lumps of tofu we respect them
as the living creatures they are the
only little buddy yeah we're a
sustainable free-range Tofurky planet he
raises tofurkey humanely from birth and
try to fill all their days with joy care
and love they love their daily shiatsu
massage pizza Fridays they love their
trips to museums of fine art and of
course their weekend cool parties and
their good little swimmers and we
breastfeed him three times a day
they really are treated humanely here at
McClellan now when you prepare the
topher keys for consumption how do you
go about how do we kill them we crush
them with a piano
the Cleland farms two turkeys we give
them love and care and then we crush
them with a PA
it's government line
[Applause]
you